let's tackle the hunter hunter Iceberg
and it's gonna be a big job because for
a series that has spent more time on
Hiatus than it has being published this
goes super deep yoshihiro Togashi is a
very unique author capable of writing
with obsessive levels of excruciating
detail but one who is also willing to
abandon any given idea depending on what
takes his own personal interest at the
time and as a result there are a lot of
overlooked Connections in Hunter Hunter
because Togashi does take the time to
insert them but not necessarily draw our
attention to them if that makes sense
hence why Hunter Hunter may be the
biggest iceberg in all of manga but
let's begin with our basic top tier the
ax in Hunter Hunter to put it quite
simply you don't pronounce the ax and
don't trust anyone who does and there's
no real deep meaning as to why tagashi
came up with the title for the series
whilst watching downtown who were famous
in the Western World for the no-life
punishment games and in this case
Togashi was amused by a bit where
phrases were repeated for Comic effect
and so he named his new series Hunter
Hunter on a whim and as for why Togashi
chose to jam an X in between those two
words again it's completely arbitrary
it's sort of like how he added two stars
into the U Hawk show title but you don't
pronounce it you star you star hakusha
if you call it Hunter x Hunter you are
empirically objectively and most of all
morally wrong and if you need more
evidence and here's a video of Togashi
quite literally saying the correct title
number two Duan is Togashi speaking of
Togashi he actually makes an appearance
in Hunter Hunter as the self-insert
character of dwin one of the Greed
Island Game Masters whose name was
changed by Jing without doing's
permission but when we first meet when
he's playing some of them their video
games completely surrounded by trash and
if you look carefully it contains
cardboard cutouts of various female
characters but also there is a box with
togashi's author avatar on it the
trademark dog wearing the glasses and
this is one of those classic art
imitates life scenarios he goes at one
stage tagashi's living conditions
weren't exactly too dissimilar from
doons but I do find it quite endearing
that Togashi decided to poke fun at
himself like this now as for characters
who are also other things this goes over
the heads of most casual readers and
Watchers at nanika the presence residing
with an alaka is actually one of the
Dark Continent calamities this is never
referenced in the anime in fact none of
the calamities except for the Chimera
ants are actually named in the anime but
then the manga tagashi did a little
sneaky extra page with nanaka revealing
that they are from the Dark Continent
and with that in mind nanaka is clearly
the Calamity eye the codependence of
Desire what we don't know however is if
nanaka is the only eye to exist within
the human realm because our introduction
to I implies that there are an entire
species of infinitely powerful wish
granting calamities out there and in
general the Dark Continent may have
played a much bigger role in the series
than we thought even right from the
beginning with little hints here and
there such as the hermit scroll an often
forgotten item sought after by hanser
which in the 2011 anime is called the
ultimate ninja scroll and in the 1999
anime is called nothing because they
don't mention it but this is the whole
reason why Hanzo became a hunter which
he revealed to tonpo of all people in
chapter 6 where he says I want a license
so I can hunt The elusive hermit scroll
rumor is that it's in a country barred
to commoners which in turn has resulted
in a lot of speculation that the scroll
is on the Dark Continent a location that
Hans are rather conveniently right now
and just so happens to be on his way to
that's not the only potential Dark
Continent item though because fellow
haunted Melody is searching for a piece
of music known as the Sonata of Darkness
said to have been composed by Satan
himself in fact all Melody heard from it
was a brief flute solo and it
transformed her body into something that
tagashi has never even dared to show us
but it even made karapika shiver which
is the kind of power that we've only
seen performed by calamities and it's
entirely possible that this Sonata is
another curse from this horrific
landmass still not quite as cursed as
gonzan though this is a favorite of mine
but if you pay special attention to
Gonza bandages you'll notice that every
Arc results in varying degrees of arm
injuries for gone in the hunter examin
arm was broken by Hanzo in Heaven's
Arena his other arm was broken by Gita
during York New City his hand was
brutalized by Nobunaga while arm
wrestling an arm was just blown right
the crap off by genthero and Greed
Island and in the Chimera and talk we
went all the way and had pito's corpse
completely severing on meanwhile in the
rare rocks where gon doesn't suffer an
arm injury they're taken up by gone
recovering from said injury like the
Zodiac family and the German election
Arc so gonzam is quite legendary but so
is the body part of another protagonist
if you've been involved in the hunter
hunter fandom for long enough you'll
have likely stumbled upon the idea that
Leorio is exceptionally well hung this
like most of the weirder parts of the
iceberg comes directly from the 1999
anime during the hunter exam Arc there's
a filler section where Leorio takes a
shower then emerges back into the room
fully nude and karapika is simply
awestruck That's What I Call refreshing
with that reaction prompting fans to go
hey leoria must be something something
pretty special down there this scene is
actually recorded on the anime bot
scenes Wiki which keeps chronological
record of all bath and shower scenes by
the dates they originally aired in Japan
and in case you're wondering the bot
seemed to come directly before leoria
was the first episode of Initial D
meanwhile the one to come directly after
it was from Excel Saga the 1999 anime in
general is just an absolute Gold Mine of
weird and this is definitely not the
last we've heard from it however this is
the first we've heard of feitan's
unknown language in the manga during the
fight against sazan vetan appears to
slip into a form of Chinese at least
that's what it looks like to us
uncultured Western swine however the
characters that appear are actually a
made-up language which in the anime is
spoken as inverter Japanese so it may be
from feitan's original home before he
was dumped on meteor City or it could
just be a language made up by feitan
himself there were lots of video tapes
about language learning so you know
maybe feitan got inspired one day but
the language has yet to be referenced in
any other aspect of the series sticking
with the Phantom troop for a bit did you
know that charnock's fortune As Told by
lovely Ghostwriter during York New City
actually came true when crawler used
this ability charnock's Fortune read as
such you must not phone because at the
most important time it won't work you
won't be able to answer the phone either
because one time out of three on the
other end will be the god of death so
not good things and what's worse is that
all of the above things actually
happened at the most important time
charl Knox phone didn't work because
crawler had borrowed his black voice
ability charnock also wasn't able to
enter his literal phone as he received a
call just as he spotted hisoka and of
course that the hisoka ended up becoming
the Phantom troops personal god of death
killing Sherlock should also be noted
that hisoka's troop number was 4 AKA she
AKA death the interesting thing is that
lovely Ghostwriter is only able to
predict Futures about a month in advance
at most and shell knocks inevitable
death occurred more than a year after he
received the fortune so either it was
some sort of phenomenal coincidence or
the god of death really had it in for
shanok and throughout god of death
hisoka is commonly considered to be the
fifth protagonist of Hunter Hunter and
this is mostly due to his birthday being
June 6 or 6 6 and this is because our
four are the main protagonists share
this birthday trend of double numbers
such as gone being born on the 5th of
the fifth and killua being born on the
7th of the seventh it's a nice little
hint at the Double title you know the
hunter hunter so the birthdays of the
protagonists are also just double
numbers as for the protagonists many
kintagashi fans may have noticed the
distinct similarity between the four
core characters of Fontana and the core
protagonist of Yu hakusha there appears
to be some sort of formula at play here
and that formula actually has a name
it's called the four temperament
Ensemble this creates a four-piece
emotional pie chart to provide a diverse
four-player cast based on the factors of
introversion versus extroversion and
emotional stability versus emotional not
that instability I believe it's called
but for example gone is extroverted and
emotionally stable I mean I don't know
at least in the beginning eventually
it's none of those which is actually
very interesting because by the end of
the series when all the Chimera antok
stuff happens he turns from extroverted
and stable to in introverted and
unstable that that's character growth or
character ungrowth meanwhile to use this
formula kilowatt would be the
emotionally stable introvert garoppica
would be the emotionally unstable
introvert and then we would have Leorio
fulfilling the loudest of the roles as
the emotionally unstable extrovert it's
a fun little cheat sheet for writing
particularly because in this system
there is no clear group leader so
everyone can just equally play off each
other further down the iceberg we find
one of my favorite things ever which is
the hunter hunter live action musical
the nightmare of zolduk a very well
let's be generous and say interesting
retelling of the zoldic family Arc
featuring singing and dancing from the
entire assassin family and one of my
favorite Parts is this really heartfelt
song song by Silva about how proud he is
of kilua and coming to terms with the
idea that his son might not want to lead
the life of an assassin also hisoka's
there for different for reasons oh and
also they do blackface with Canary so
that happened and while we're on
socially controversial subjects let's
just do it and Tackle nephepito's gender
this is one of those things where no
matter what you say someone's going to
correct you on the internet he goes
everyone has their own interpretation
because that's what it's meant to be to
put it simply Pito is a character
deliberately designed to be ambiguous in
the mangapito is drawn as more of a cute
young boy whereas the 2011 anime depicts
Pito as significantly more feminine in
both mediums Pito is generally referred
to as he by the ants although those are
rare circumstances you'll find that when
referring to Peter pronouns are almost
never used but there is also some
distinct female symbology at play like a
mother protecting a child and also on
one volume cover Pito was even depicted
in the position of the Virgin Mary the
hunt Hunter battle collection does State
Pito to be female but the official Data
Book refers to Pito very unambiguously
as he that's this data book and it's
it's kind of unreliable we'll get into
it later but so is the battle collection
though it's a miscellaneous game that
tokashi had nothing to do with and in
the end given that nefepito's name is a
fusion of a male God and a female French
children's book character tagashi's
intention was to create a completely
gender-neutral character I suppose one
way you could see it is that Peter was
male in the manga and female in the
anime but the tldr is that Pito was
whatever you interpret them to be but
nobody can objectively State one way or
the other now here's one of the most
common questions in Hunter Hunter that
all of us have asked at one stage and
that is who the hell is this guy so
during the 2011 anime this this dude man
just appears in Heaven's Arena and
starts commentating on the gone in
hisoka fight no context is ever given to
who he is or why he's here where he is
doing the things it is that he's doing
nothing we don't get anything but I have
the answers this guy's name is Baka Ki
eldogra also known as Prince Barker
which translated is Prince idiot and
he's the main character of another of
tagashi's Works level E and fun fact
Prince Barker was voiced by hisoka's
voice actor in the level e anime however
in the hunter hunter anime for whatever
reason Prince Barker has a different
voice actor and while Prince Parker did
appear in the original Manga version of
these events the 1999 anime I was always
just decided to do its own thing and
instead inserted yoshihiro tagashi
equipped with his dog with glasses
Avatar although funnily enough tagashi
doesn't Voice himself here he's actually
portrayed by takash who also plays Jonas
the dissector during the trick Tower
portion of the hunter exam in the 2011
anime he's also dewfeld in one piece so
the guy has a tendency to voice these
very minor underworld characters now
speaking of miners that's that's what
gone is and that makes our next subject
very tricky because we're going to talk
about gone's virginity not because I
want to but because Togashi has implied
that it no longer exists this is
probably one of the most controversial
aspects of Hunter Hunter because it's in
the section of story where gone goes on
a date with Paul and just as a bit of a
reminder Palm is 22 and during this time
gone is somewhere between 11 to 12. also
Palm forced him to do it and referred to
gone as a quote tease but this gets
stranger because later gone and killer
they do the Bro thing and you know hit
the gym where kilowa proceeds to ask
about gon's history with women and
surprisingly what we find out is that
gone has a history with women in gon's
own words sometimes ships with
all-female Crews stopped by whale Island
some of them only go out with younger
guys they took me into town and taught
me a lot of stuff they called those
types cougars it should be noted that
the 2011 anime changed the Cougar Line
to be Fanatics instead which I guess
tones down the sexual connotation
somewhat and they also say that gone
took them into town instead of them
taking gone into town I guess that gives
him a bit more agency so make of that
what you will but what I make of it is
that it's still one of the strange
choices that tagashi has made in Hunter
Hunter for a more age-appropriate
romance within the background of Hunter
Hunter there is a subplot between hisoka
and Machi a one-sided romance where
hisoka is constantly hitting on her and
in the original Japanese manga he quite
blatantly asks her hey you want to do
the sex again this was toned down in
every subsequent version firstly in the
English translation he just asked her
out to dinner and both anime adaptations
decided to go down that road as well and
you know that you've you've like really
crossed the line when the 1999 anime
says that you've gone too far because
we're talking about the same adaptation
that had killer while offering to watch
porn with gone that is a story for
another time though meanwhile the story
for right now is the mystery of the
missing zoldic family member so if
you've watched the 2011 anime you'll be
familiar with this hill who out of the
entire zodiac family which even features
the late game edition of alka however
there is a character here that you will
not recognize as in between kilua and
Maha there is an unknown's old dick
silhouette assumed by many fans to be a
grandmother figure the reason why this
is weird is because this character makes
no appearance in the manga or ever again
in any medium for that matter I don't
know where this design came from whether
it was something tagashi gave to them or
something the anime made up however
while on the tour bus in the manga the
guide makes mention that the zoldik
family consists of five siblings the
parents a set of grandparents and a
great grandfather so this mysterious
older grandmother is implied to be the
wife of Xena however that gets called
into question because the Zodiac family
is the Zodiac family is tricky and
inconsistent because the great
grandfather Maha zoldik should actually
be the great great grandfather because
there is a second unknown zoldic in
between Maha and Xena however it gets
even trickier because we don't actually
know if Maha is indeed actually Maha
this will make sense soon how is subject
to a whole ton of confusion because
while he is commonly referred to as Maha
zoldik this name has never been used in
the actual story it was a name only
given to him via the official hunt
Hunt's dartbook again this data book by
the way it has you know a lot of
interesting information in it but the
problem is that a lot of it is very
contradictory and in many cases just
flat out wrong which makes the book of
data very very untrustworthy and even if
Togashi did write the key details
himself he has a tendency to either
forget or just not care and retcon stuff
later and this Maha business was
especially called into question with the
introduction of zigzoldik in Isaac
nataros flashback a man who essentially
looks just like a young Maha and so the
current idea is that Maha and zigzoldik
are the same person and it's here that I
want to take the time to point out that
we are still only on the first layer of
this Iceberg when I said that Hunter
Hunter went deep I meant it what we've
covered so far are really the most
surface level topics and secrets so this
is gonna take us a while but you won't
believe the sheer Insanity that's coming
in next video